dans 10 jours c'est Noël alors les
vacances des fêtes arrivent à grands pas
est-ce que vous avez l'intention de
rester à la maison où vous avez des
projets de voyage prendre l'avion pour
voyager au Canada à l'international des
voyageurs qui gardent un goût amer quand
même des retards des annulations de vol
l'été dernier il faut s'attendre à quoi
dans les aéroports canadiens pour la
période des fêtes on a discute avec John
Gradec les directeurs du programme de
gestion de l'aviation université méghill
bonsoir Monsieur Gradec bonsoir madame
alors on a effectivement de mauvais
souvenirs de ce qui s'est passé pendant
l'été une vague de retard d'annulation
de souvenirs de ces images avec les
bagages qui s'entassent est-ce que la
situation s'est améliorée là au cours
des six derniers mois oui je pense que
oui je pense qu'avec tous les embauches
que les compagnies aériennes ont fait et
que les Européens ont fait aussi et je
vois que maintenant on a les effectifs
nécessaires pour supporter l'aéroport le
groupe la grosse question maintenant
est-ce qu'ils ont assez d'expérience
est-ce qu'ils sont vraiment des gens qui
savent quoi faire pendant les périodes
de
avantages qu'on va voir et mais le
nombre de nombre de factures est là
maintenant ça va voir est-ce qu'ils sont
efficaces vraiment pour opérer l'horaire
qui est prévu parce que cette semaine on
a eu des aéroports entre autres piersen
on a ressenti une volonté de se défaire
un peu de l'image qui leur collait à la
peau depuis l'été celle d'un des pires
aéroports au monde pendant l'été en ce
qui concerne le taux de retard le taux
d'annulation est-ce qu'on va pouvoir se
défaire de cette image là est-ce que
vraiment ça s'est amélioré à ce chapitre
là je pense que oui je pense que
lorsqu'on regarde qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé à l'été on soit personne et même
un Trudeau on avait des des retards
incompréhensibles on voyait des retards
de deux trois jours même sur les départs
maintenant on voit que avec le niveau
d'effectif qu'ils ont maintenant et la
construction des horaires et la façon
que les oreilles ont été construits pour
la période des fêtes qu'on a pris des
leçons de l'été et que j'espère bien que
les leçons vont prendre des moi des bons
résultats dans les prochaines semaines
donc là vous nous donnez un peu espoir
mais monsieur greatest il y a quelques
semaines vous disiez il y a de réels
possibilités qu'on revive à tout le
moins certaines difficultés pendant le
temps des fêtes qu'est-ce qui vous
amenez à dire ça je pense que la chose
c'est qu'il y a toujours un risque sur
les opérations et c'est la chose qui
arrive maintenant c'est que on a des
problèmes peut-être potentiels au niveau
de la température commencer sans doute
on a une tempête qui sont bien vers nous
dans les 48 prochaines heures mais il y
a aussi je me suis un peu
concerné vraiment avec l'expérience des
individus qu'ils ont embauché le nombre
d'individus qu'ils ont sur les lieux et
satisfaisant pour payer leurs rêves pour
moi c'est vraiment est-ce qu'ils ont les
compétences est-ce qu'ils ont
l'expérience est-ce qu'ils savent
comment on peut lire une ligne érienne
et une opération aéroportuaire avec le
taux d'achat qu'on va voir dans les
prochains jours au-delà de l'embauche de
la main d'oeuvre qui ont souhaite
laissera au rendez-vous malgré tous les
virus aussi qui continuent de circuler
les aéroports ont fait la promotion une
semaine de différents outils qu'ils ont
développé pour tenter d'améliorer
l'expérience du voyageur on nous a dit
on a maintenant des applications qui
vous permettent de suivre en temps réel
la longueur des fils d'attente de
réserver votre plage horaire pour votre
passage au point de sécurité est-ce que
ça fonctionne ça vous auriez monsieur je
pense que regarde l'impact de tous ces
jouets qu'ils ont qu'ils ont placé en
main et c'est ils ont investi investi
dans les millions qu'ils ont investi
c'est vraiment j'ai pas vu la preuve que
c'est vraiment avoir une ça va voir un
bénéfice au niveau de l'expérience
passager à l'aéroport je pense que ça va
être vraiment voir l'impact dans les
prochaines semaines si ces technologies
c'est une nouvelle approche ces
applications vont vraiment changer la
façon que les passagers sont traités à
les aéroports on sait pas encore c'est
quand même un peu dans la bonne
direction on l'espère bon évidemment la
pandémie a fait exploser la demande
cette année
à la suite de la pandémie devrait-je
dire puisque ce sera la première période
des fêtes où on peut voyager sans trop
de restriction en trois ans les prix des
billets d'avion d'ailleurs est assez
élevé en cette fin d'année est-ce que
c'est le manque d'offre le manque de
concurrence pourquoi on a des billets
d'avion si élevés en ce moment c'est
c'est une situation normale pendant les
fêtes ça fait des années si vous voyagez
pendant les 40 dernières années que moi
je le faisais c'est toujours une
situation que pendant les périodes de
pointe les tarifs montent et puis si on
regarde les tarifs Montréal Los Angeles
ou le 20 ou 21 décembre puis revenir
après les fêtes au-dessus de 1000
dollars pour l'aller Montréal Los
Angeles si on veut aller à Los Angeles
dit-on au mois de janvier mi-janvier fin
janvier on a des diabète d'environ 400 à
450 dollars aller-retour d'abord c'est
toujours une question traditionnelle que
pendant les périodes de fait pendant
l'été les tarifs sont plus élevés et
autrement les petites se baissent savoir
c'est situation normal dans les lignes
aériennes et la frustration est d'autant
plus grande quand on paie le biais cher
qu'on arrive à l'aéroport et que le vol
ne décolle pas on évoquait tout à
l'heure les virus qui circulent vous
avez dit il y a suffisamment d'employés
est-ce qu'il y en aura assez pour faire
la rotation si vous voulez si un pilote
ou un agent de bord tombe malade ça a
été la cause de plusieurs annulations ça
pendant l'été monsieur greatest
les lignes aériennes ont appris je pense
que là sur un si on regarde
les discussions qui ont eu qui ont lieu
dans deux dernières semaines entre les
compagnies aériennes et européens et le
ministre transport je pense que le
ministre était vraiment bien défini dans
la situation de dire que on a on sait
maintenant le nombre de passagers qu'on
va avoir pendant les fêtes assurez-vous
que vous avez les effectifs nécessaires
et surtout assurez-vous que vous avez
des exercices en réserve pour s'assurer
qu'on a les effectifs nécessaires pour
opérer les vols d'abord je pense que il
y a de la question de
d'intervent la suffisamment de personnel
d'une question donc le ministre
transport tous les Canadiens d'asper que
les compagnies aériennes ont fait le
travail nécessaire pour sociologique les
effectifs sont là est-ce que vous avez
des voyageurs ceux qui préparent leur
départ monsieur groadec par exemple
est-ce que c'est encore pertinent
d'arriver 3 heures à l'avance pour les
vols internationaux est-ce qu'il faut
même que ce soit plus que ça pour les
fesses tout dépend des gens la façon que
vous gérez votre risque au niveau de
risque et est-ce que vous aimez le
risque et puis moi je considère que
lorsqu'on regarde les voyages surtout
les voyages en hiver c'est vraiment
nécessaire que les passagers soient là
soit à l'aéroport au moins deux heures à
l'avance moi j'ai laissé les premiers
vols internationaux que vous allez 3
heures à l'avance et que ça continue à
rester comme ça je pense que les bagages
humains sont là et puis beaucoup de
patience je pense que ça c'est le
meilleur conseil de la soirée merci
beaucoup monsieur pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI